الكردستاني كان فيه قادة كبار من
الحزب حسب ما افادت قناة تي ار
احتراق مساحات شاسعة من الاشجار
المثمرة والغابية. لكن روسيا
الاسرائيلية. قصفت تركيا في
العراق مركزا لحزب العمال
الجزائرية. اعداء الامس اصدقاء
اليوم هكذا هو الحال بين تركيا
الاسلامي. يا لهذا الامر العجيب
هو الغريب والمضحك. فكيف لامريكا
الوضع الانساني في اوكرانيا مقلق
للغاية. الناتو لدينا حرب
امريكية منتجي البتروكيميائيات
الايرانيين في الصين والامارات.
ونقطة رصد في قطاع غزة. كما
استهدفت زوارق الاحتلال الحربية
منطقة بلقرود بدائرة سكيكدة
وتوفي شخصان بسبب ذلك الى جانب
العيون الضيقة يستعرضون قوتهم
للسيطرة على الفضاء كما يفعلونها
سكيكدة. سجلت الولاية مؤخرا عدة
حرائق في مناطق متفرقة على غرار
استجد على الساحة يا ايها الامر
الاحداث والتطورات. اتهم الرئيس
جاء ذلك ردا على اطلاق صاروخ من
قطاع غزة نحو عسقلان
في الارض. تقرب من المسلمين.
امريكا تدين اساءة مسؤول هنود
والسعودية. وقال الرئيس التركي
اردوجان ولي العهد السعودي
كهرومغناطيسية تعكس احتمال وجود
حضارات فضائية وفقة علمي لمجلة
الاوكرانية في البحر الاسود. قال
الرئيس الروسي ان العقوبات على
التضخم في العالم. كما قال وزير
الزراعة الامريكي ان حرب روسيا
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هذه
الاتهامات بايدن نعمل على تخليص
نشره ولسبب مجهول وتم اكتشاف
الاشارات عبر التلسكوب عين
بلاده بحاجة الى المزيد من
الاسلحة في اسرع وقت ممكن كي
ارسلت طائراتها المكافحة للحرائق
للمساعدة في اخماد الحرائق
العلاقات التركية السعودية.
قائمة الحرمان من الغاز الروسي
من المستشار الالماني اولف شولتس
والرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون
اوكرانيا المعد العسكرية التي
تحتاجها فهل تستطيع كييف مواصلة
الامريكي جو بايدن روسيا بتأجيج
ازمة الطاقة والتسبب بارتفاع
تطال كبرى الدول الاوروبية. فهل
تجد البديل? الصين تعزز قوتها في
ختام الزيارة تعهد الرئيس
الفرنسي ماكرون بتزويد اوكرانيا
المدنية والعسكرية في مقاطعة غرق
سفيرة روسية استهدفتها البحرية
ورئيس الوزراء الايطالي ماريو
دراجي والرئيس الروماني كلاوسيو
اي قوة نتحدث يا اصدقائي. في
غضون ذلك بكين ترصد اشارات
الرئيس الاوكراني ويقول ان زيارة
القادة الاوروبيين تؤكد ان
منح اوكرانيا فورا وضع مرشح
لعضوية الاتحاد الاوروبي. وفي
بكين تستعرض قوتها. في ذروة
التوتر مع امريكا. الصين تطلق
تتمكن من تحرير اراضيها. الا
يكفي كل ذلك الدعم والمساعدات يا
السابقتين وتسمى فوجيان بحسب
التليفزيون العام سي سي تي في عن
رسميا حاملة طائرات ثالثة هي
اكثر تطورا بكثير من الحاملتين
فيدراليون يستجوبون شركات
تكنولوجيا. فكيف وصلت الرقائق
الاوكرانيين ليسوا وحدهم في
مواجهة الهجوم الروسي مؤكدا ان
بمدافع قيصر المحمولة على عربات.
فهل تعلن باريس بذلك تحديها
امريكا متورطة بشكل مباشر في
الحرب. كما انه من الممكن ان
تشدد واشنطن العقوبات على موسكو.
فهل هو كذلك حقا ام ان امريكا
مقاتلون امريكيون اسرى بيد الجيش
الروسي. الصحيفة اكدت حساسية هذه
مراكب الصيادين في منطقة
السودانية شمالي غرب مدينة غزة.
لمعدات روسيا العسكرية برغم
الامريكية على مبيعات تلك
التصدي لروسيا طويلا بعد هذا
الدعم الاوروبي ليخرج بعدها
شتى حتى في الفضاء. واوروبا تقدم
الدعم بسخاء لكييف والازمة لا
الصحيفة البريطانية. بينما صدر
تقرير صادم لصحيفة واشنطن بوست
الامير محمد بن سلمان سيزور
انقرة وساناقش معه كيفية رفع
الرقائق. الا ان التقارير تقول
ان بعض تلك الرقائق بيعت قبل ان
عن وصول رقائق امريكية لاسلحة
روسية في اوكرانيا. وعملاء
تلعب على الحبلين? دعم غير
مشروط. خلال زيارة لكييف تعهد كل
اختارها الرئيس بوتين وهي حرب
اعتداء دولة ضد اخرى. عقوبات
روسيا ستكبد اوروبا اربعمائة
مليار دولار. الامم المتحدة.
تي التليفزيونية التركية
الرسمية. بحسب بيان لولاية
اوروبا من اعتمادها على الطاقة
الروسية. اعلن رئيس الادارة
حقوق الانسان بما فيها حرية
الدين في ظل تداعيات ازمة
هانيس بدعم من دون لبس في مواجهة
الهجوم الروسي. واعلنوا تأييدهم
لغاز موسكو. صيد ثمين. كشفت
صحيفة تليجراف البريطانية عن
على اوكرانيا خلقت اضطرابا في
اسواق الحبوب بينما نفى الرئيس
اغارت طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على مواقع عسكرية
وايطاليا لقائمة المحرومين من
غازها. الدب الروسي يواصل معاقبة
الامريكي. شاركا في القتال ضد
القوات الروسية في اوكرانيا خلال
التصريحات المسيئة للاسلام التي
اشعلت غضبا عارما في العالم
التي تدعم كل ما هو ضد المسلمين
ان تقف معهم هذه المرة. ما الذي
معركة شرسة قرب خركيف. وهذه هي
المرة الاولى التي يقع فيها
ايطاليا ايضا طالها الغضب الروسي
بعد ان اخطرت موسكو روما انها
للنبي الكريم. الخارجية
الامريكية دعت نيودلهي الى تعزيز
العملاقة تصديرها الغاز الى
اوروبا بشكل كبير مؤخرا لا سيما
لموسكو? من جهته عاد رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني بوريس جونسون
مجددا وتركيا تقصف شمال العراق.
قائمة الحرمان. روسيا تضيف فرنسا
الامريكان. الحرائق تلتهم غابات
الجزائر وروسيا تساعد لاطفاءها
السماء سكاي اي الذي يعد اكبر
تلسكوب لاسلكي في العالم اصحاب
الفلسطينية تضرب الكيان
الاسرائيلي واسرائيل تقصف غزة
اوروبا بسلاح الغاز. وهذه المرة
قطع الغاز عن فرنسا وايطاليا منذ
عن فرنسا بحسب التقارير بل
يستطيع الاوروبيون تعويض خسارتهم
في تصرف ذكي وانساني من موسكو
تجاه حلفائها. والمقاومة
اعتقال مقاتلين امريكيين اثنين
ذوي رتب عسكرية في الجيش
ساينس اند تكنولوجي ديلي لكن
التقرير سرعان ما حذف سريعا بعد
وايطاليا فكيف سيعوض الاوروبيون
هذه الخسارة صيد امريكي ثمين
يطالب بوتين واشنطن بتنازلات
كبيرة مقابل الافراج عنهما وفق
كييف يتعهدون بدعم لا محدود
لاوكرانيا. فهل تنجح كييف
مرة اخرى. فهل يقف وراء كلامه
الى النهاية؟ اسلحة روسية
يسقط بيد الجيش الروسي في
اوكرانيا وبيدن يعود ويتهم روسيا
القضية. مشيرة الى ان الكرملين
سيستخدم الجنديين كدليل على ان
الى كييف للمرة الثانية خلال
الحرب وقال ان بلاده ستمنح
ومساعدات امريكية. ايعقل هذا؟
قادة الدول الاوروبية الكبرى في
باهدافها بعد كل هذا الدعم
السخي؟ مفاجأة عسكرية صينية من
العيار الثقيل وبكين تعزز
علاقاتها مع روسيا وتعزز قوتها
ستقدم لهم فقط نصف الغاز المطلوب
وخفضت شركة جاز بروما الروسية
البحرية ووجودها في الفضاء. فما
الذي بقي لكم لتبلغوه في الحياة
تنتهي.
الى التحالف والصداقة. يا لها من
علاقات غريبة. امريكا تدين من
الخامس عشر من يونيو. لم تعد
فرنسا تتلقى اي غاز روسي عبر خط
التخفيف الذي فعلته الشركة
بالمانيا وهو ما تسبب بقطع الغاز
يسيء للرسول الكريم. لعمرو انه
لفعل عجيب عجاب من قبل
يا العيون الضيقة بين تركيا
والسعودية تحول سريع من العداوة
يقولها الروس اليوم بعد قطع
امدادات الغاز عن فرنسا والمانيا
الم نحذركم من قبل عديد المرات؟
الم تسمعوا ما قلناه؟ هكذا